dans cette forêt à quelques kilomètres
seulement de Kiev c'est unité d'assaut
ukrainienne s'entraîne au combat tous
ici se prépare pour l'éventuelle
contre-offensive de printemps promise
depuis des semaines par l'État ukrainien
contre les forces russes
ce ne sera pas facile mais nous y
parviendrons bientôt ce n'est qu'une
question de temps pour mener cette
contre-offensive les Occidentaux ont
promis début d'année plusieurs centaines
de charme comme le fameux léopard 2 dont
certains ont déjà été livrés mais pour
frapper l'ennemi en profondeur qui est
demande aussi plus d'artillerie à longue
portée malgré la livraison récente de
systèmes anti-missiles patriotes
l'Ukraine a besoin de nouvelles
munitions de défense anti-aérienne
objectif tenir à distance les avions et
les hélicoptères russes
maître du temps à prendre ce genre de
décision c'est perdre du temps pour la
paix c'est perdre la vie de nos
combattants qui n'ont pas encore reçu
les outils vitaux de défense en quantité
appropriée
depuis des mois l'Ukraine demande aussi
la livraison d'avions de chasse aux
Occidentaux seule la Pologne et la
Slovaquie ont pour l'instant franchi le
pas avec des Mig29 de conception
soviétique mais volodimeersalens qui lui
réitère son besoin d'avion plus moderne
comme les chasseurs américains F16
Washington et ses alliés refusent pour
le moment de les livrer par peur d'une
escalade avec la Russie